I talked about the larry elder interview
in that and where after he beat me
senseless my editors and my director and
my producers wanted to cut it they
didn't want it to air and I said guys if
I'm anything that I purport to be as an
interviewer we have to put it up and you
know I saw it get clipped a million
times on YouTube and larry elder
destroys and capital letters lib [ __ ]
and you know blah blah blah but what I
realized almost within a day was holy
cow people were having their wake-up
moment right alongside of me hey
everyone its Andrew Klavan and we're
here with the don't burn this book book
club we're doing Chapter five check your
facts not your privilege which is a
chapter after my own heart
I'm very big on facts what reminded me
of what Ronald Reagan once said and he
said it's not that Democrats don't know
anything it's that everything they know
happens to be untrue and I think that
this is something that comes to all of
us when we are as they say red pill when
we start to realize that all the things
we took for granted all the positions we
took for granted really aren't based on
any kind of facts that based on the kind
of emotional browbeating that the left
uses instead of ideas I mean this is one
of the things about the left they don't
have a lot of ideas but they have a lot
of techniques
we're silencing people with ideas and
for frightening people with ideas and I
have to say one of the things I liked
about this this chapters is packed with
facts it's packed with information stuff
you can use to beat up your grandmother
at Thanksgiving if she has a bad opinion
but I think but I think the most
important part of this chapter is the
discussion about the fact that when we
talk to each other when liberals and
conservatives talk to one another they
are talking in in different languages I
would go even further in saying they're
talking from a completely different
point of view so Dave I'd like to talk
to you about that because that was the
thing that really grabbed me was this
idea that we're not communicating at all
we think we're arguing with one another
but we're actually not putting across
our ideas at all is that a fair way to
say it it is a fair way and Clavin
before I say anything else one of the
reasons that I wanted you to handle this
chapter is because I think you are one
of the better communicators we have on
these type of ideas because
often it is that lens that is the
screwed up part it's hard to tell how
people think about the world where their
biases are and everything else and I
find you to be a very clear communicator
on this stuff and of course you do work
with that fast-talking Orthodox Jew
who's always talking what's that thing
about facts and feelings right there's
something that he's always saying about
that so I thought there was you're
around him a lot so I thought it would
work so yeah we can dive into some of
the nitty-gritty of the specifics but I
I agree that the part about the lenses
really is is the most interesting part
here you know some of us view the world
so me for example I really view the
world through mostly what is thought of
in an American sense as a libertarian
lens that I want you as the individual
to basically do be able to do whatever
you want but not purely whatever you
want you can't infringe on your
neighbor's rights you can't steal from
people you can't murder people things
like that and this is where I always say
people always say well Dave what's the
difference between a classical liberal
and a libertarian and I always say well
I want some a little bit more of the
basic guidelines around society then I
think a pure libertarian does and then
we have you know people that view things
through more of a conservative lens that
generally is more that they're trying to
defend the family and sort of long
fought long fought battles that sort of
a view built Western civilization that
has sort of fought against barbarism as
they would call it and I actually have
become very sympathetic to that view as
well and then there's sort of the more
progressive or or I think it's really
called liberal lens although I always
I'm trying to clean up the difference
between sort of progressive and liberal
which is more sort of about the
oppressed and the oppressor and I think
that's the most muddled lens these days
because if you live in the West and
especially if you live in the United
States you are not oppressed you have
actually the greatest privilege there is
which is that you live in a free society
that isn't to say it is perfect we know
it is not perfect but I don't believe a
perfect society can exist I think when
once you try to create a perfect society
you're gonna have to take out a lot of
people to do it because people are
imperfect so I think
that that general idea of sort of
figuring out how you look at the world
what what sort of pecking order you put
the importance of these things in is a
really important thing and then to your
point then when you find oh well here's
someone who looks at the world so
differently than me they don't accept
facts as I accept facts or they have a
what they view to be a completely
different set of facts well then you
could start unpacking that a little bit
because you can have an appreciation oh
it's just that their hierarchy is a
little different than my our hierarchy
and we have to figure out how to how to
be able to do some talking here you know
like like you I came over from the left
and I shifted over to the right almost
not knowing it because I was out of the
country when it happened I was living in
England and I came back and found I had
shifted to the right and I had this
innocent sense that oh wow you know if
only my fellow friends on the Left knew
what I now knew they would see that they
have made this terrible mistake and I
went around explaining to my former
friends who now no longer talk to me and
and when I follow you on twitter I see
you often saying to people you know what
you just said is not based in fact or
now you're starting to see the facts why
don't you come on my show and we'll talk
about it how often do people respond to
that how often do you get people were
willing to engage with you in this
journey well unfortunately it's it's
becoming less and less because so many
of the people on the left I think have
turned from say honest debate to just
personal attacks and I am always willing
to open my door or in this case my skype
to anyone that wants to talk to me
respectfully but if you're endlessly
going to attack me or attack my motives
or lie about me you know there's a
certain set of people that will just lie
about you relentlessly and then say see
and you won't bring me on your show and
it's like well that's not really the
game that I'm interested in playing but
it is fascinating to me what you're
talking about there which is that you
thought because I think a lot of X
lefties which by the way I think is
truly the biggest growing and unspoken
political group in the United States
it's the it's the decent liberals who
are waking up against leftism but I
think a lot of them are sort of thinking
what you just laid
out there which is oh I've woken up to
some stuff it clearly is more fact-based
and and and more freeing as a human
being and suddenly I'm realizing oh
these conservatives that I thought were
the bad guys or whatever they're not so
bad but they're afraid to say it and if
and not only afraid to say it they're
shocked that people don't start coming
with them but there's a reason for that
and that that reason of course is that
you know once you've called everybody
else bigots and racists you know that
will be turned against you
but one of the things that just further
your point you know it's interesting
because I know that you and I have have
still some pretty significant political
disagreements you are pro-life I make a
pro-choice argument in this book I think
you're for the death penalty right I'm
for I'm not for the death penalty as it
stands but I'm potentially for the death
penalty well okay so so I'm against the
death penalty I've heard some great
arguments dennis prager makes of I think
a fantastic argument for the death
penalty I just don't like the idea of
giving the state that much power I'm
still for some level of public education
I'm for dignity with death you should be
able to make choices at the end I'm for
legalizing marijuana I mean we could go
into a bunch of things that you and you
and I don't really see eye-to-eye on but
I think the purpose of this chapter was
also to show people people on the right
they're willing to sit there and do it
sit there and and debate it and and go
through the all the grit and the dirt
that you have to get to to be able to
form a functioning society and
unfortunately that doesn't really exist
on the other side you know you start
this chapter chapter 5 check your facts
not your privilege you started with you
having to debate with Larry elder and I
did feel sorry for you because that's
like shooting a nail gun into court you
know I mean the guy has a real mastery
of facts and information but but you
know it was about racism and black
people in America and we're having this
conversation on a day when the Pulitzer
Prize has been given to the New York
Times more completely dishonest take on
slavery and black people their 1619
project so much of the division between
us is keyed around race a lot of it is
key to around gender but but so much of
it starts with this idea that somehow
we are perpetually in a racist state of
systemic racism in this country and
Larry elder in your chapter he basically
takes you a task and he says show me
show me where that racism is the
question I get asked more often than any
other is how can I convince people that
we are not in this state how can I
convince people that think we can we can
actually become one country despite the
color differences is that something that
you feel is possible or are these two
different languages just so completely
separate that we can't reach across that
barrier you know it's such a great
question and I would say this I don't
think I could do what I do and I suspect
you couldn't do what you do if you
didn't think it was possible to bridge
this divide it would be like what would
what would we really be doing with our
lives like why would we be talking about
these things if we didn't think that the
good ideas could ultimately you know
conquer the bad ones or that the
sunlight would expose the bad ideas or
the rest of it so you know I talked
about the larry elder interview in that
and where after he beat me senseless my
editors and my director and my producers
wanted to cut it they didn't want it to
air and I said guys if I'm anything that
I purport to be as an interviewer we
have to put it up and you know I saw it
get clipped a million times on YouTube
and larry elder destroys in capital
letters lib [ __ ] and you know blah blah
blah but what i realized almost within a
day was holy cow people were having
their wake-up moment right alongside of
me
so as i write i don't know how many
people in our biz or in any business can
say you know my best and worst
professional moment were at the exact
same time but that's truly what happened
it was my worst moment because i came to
a gunfight not ready with no weapon
attached because i just thought oh i say
things and there that's what lefties do
that it's sort of just because you say
it it is right systemic racism exists it
is right america is racist it's it's
divinely right in and of itself so it
was my worst moment because of that but
it was my best because in the face of it
once I got countered I don't know where
it came from exactly but I showed some
humility and I let it be a learning
experience for other people but to
directly answer your question about can
we get through this
I think there's a lot of people that in
many ways don't want us to get through
this there's a lot of people that thrive
on keeping racial tension stoked and and
it's the anti-racist who actually are
pushing the most racism into society the
supposed anti races who are the ones
that are obsessed with our color of our
skin and our sexuality and our gender
and the rest of it and then it's the
other side that just doesn't care about
that stuff and then they use it as oh
you don't care what color someone's skin
is you're the racist and it's like no
that's actually reverse we got to work
through this thing can we get through it
I think is like that's the billion
dollar question and I think the answer
if we can wake up enough people and
that's exactly why I wrote the book if
we can wake up enough people to exactly
what individual rights are to why the
Constitution is so great to why America
unlike any other country in the history
of the world that not only brought all
of these people here to blend in but
also keep their traditions and ethnicity
and all of those things but we also
expand rights over time right we had
slaves we got rid of it then black
people could vote women couldn't vote
now they can vote gay people can get
married we've expanded and expanded and
expanded rights and and I know that it
will be my conservative friends who in
if in the future there's some other
group of people who don't have equality
whatever you know equality under the law
doesn't mean you have to morally like
them or something like that I know that
it will be the Liberty minded people
that will defend people's ability to be
equal under the law while it's the
lefties who will be sort of using them
as a crud jewel to gain power and that
really is the important distinction it's
not just you're not just anti-racist
because you say you're your anti-racist
your anti-racist when you get out of
everyone's lives so that they can live
whatever their best life is you you now
find yourself in what I think is the the
biggest tent which is the conservative
side or the right-wing side whatever you
want to call it where there are in fact
people as you as you said yourself there
are people who hold your points of view
but there are people who hold very
different points of view and yet and yet
there is something that is bringing us
all together there is something that
makes it easy for Ben Shapiro and Dave
Rubin to be friends even when they have
complete differences of opinions what is
the moment you know you're talking you
talk about gay marriage and more freedom
for gay people I'm old enough I remember
people being literally arrested for
being gay you would you would be the
police could go into a gay bar and wait
till somebody hit on him and arrest you
for that so I actually remember that
time and it's a huge huge change and I
and I personally have been glad to see
it but for a while on the right I was
talking to myself for a while I was
saying you know we're wrong about this
we should shift over and it has shifted
somewhat but you're still in in this
tent with people who strongly disagree
with you what is it do you think that
unites them that unites you to people
that you know might have feelings about
you which are not as as open as you'd
like them to be I mean I think the
literal answer is individual rights that
that is the bedrock principle of the
right individual rights if you are a if
you are a member of a society a legal
member of society then you should be
treated equally under the law we are not
going to rejigger and reorganize things
so that everyone is exactly equal and
I've you know I've said this many times
but some people are born into more money
some people are born into less some
people are born drug-addicted some
people are some people are genuinely
lucky or in life some people make their
luck some people work hard some people
don't that the lefties are all obsessed
with those things Society can't fix
those things that's actually impossible
that's what the quest of life is about
society can just make it equal so I
think that's the literal answer I think
the figurative answer is is sort of from
an American perspective I think almost
everyone that identifies as a
conservative or a libertarian or a
classical liberal or let's say a
disaffected lefty I think there's an
innate pride in America I am deeply
deeply proud it's not even proud truly I
thank God that I am an American that I
was born in this country that is the
freest place ever you've been to my
house into my studio I have a giant
American flag sitting in there it's
about five foot by eight foot we've got
the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights on
the wall in there - I'm not doing that
for theater these are the greatest
man-made documents that have freed us
and I think there is a pride in that
that is deeply special on the right and
now try to think about what's happening
on the left I mean go through the
candidates that that ran you know the
election and the primary seem like a
lifetime ago but it was like how often
were the words liberty or freedom or
Constitution ever said ever said I keep
telling people but the one time
Constitution was said was when Kamala
Harris said she would do an executive
action on guns and Biden was like hey
but what about the Constitution and she
literally laughed in his face I I think
like his Bernie Sanders proud of the
American experiment the thing that he
says is is racist and and he basically
talks about as some sort of evil thing
and and that thing it's it's it's
dangerous it's actually dangerous it
doesn't mean that America is perfect or
always right or doesn't make bad
decisions or one president is better
than the other or something like that
but I think the ethos of let's all be in
on this together and it doesn't matter
if your great-grandparents came from
Poland and my great-grandparents came
from Korea or any other thing it's like
if you came here and you work hard that
ethos is strong on the right I'm not
sure what the defining thing on the left
is anymore when when you go through your
list of facts in this chapter you know
you have you have a hilarious line about
the pay gap between men and women saying
that the two things that would survive
an atomic war would be cockroaches and
this idea that there's a paragraph
there's not just one piece of
information that you could stamp onto
the forehead of a left winger that might
make him say oh you know what I got to
rethink this what would it be what's
this what was the start for you that
made you think hey wait a minute you
know I've really got this wrong what's
what's the string that pulls the suit
apart you know I think that the string
for me was that the rubber started
meeting the road it wasn't just that I
was waking up to these ideas and talking
to interesting thinkers so like when I
talked to Thomas Sol and we talked about
economics here's a guy who has been
railing
you know sort of against leftism and
communism and socialism for his whole
life although he was a Marxist at one
time in his life and we talked about
that too so this is another guy who was
a lefty like us and then who evolved
into something else
but I think what happened was as I
started talking about these things more
in bringing in more people with a
diverse set of views at the same time I
was also building a business here and
then when I would hear about why low
taxes and getting rid of regulation and
these things are important and then I'd
start looking at the numbers and talking
to my business manager in my accountant
and everything else in realizing man we
live I mean Andrew you and I live in a
state that is obscenely high taxed just
in the in the last week because of
Corona I've been sort of half joking
about it but it's becoming less of a
joke you know thinking about maybe maybe
it is time to get out of California and
we were crunching some numbers and it's
like the amount that I would save in a
place like Florida or Texas or
Washington or South Dakota I mean the
places that have basically zero income
tax and it's not because I want a yacht
although I would be perfectly within my
right to have a yacht it's not that I
want a yacht we only have one car
between the two of us it's not that I
want more stuff but I know if my company
is taxed less if you get regulation out
of the way what can I do you know what I
would do I would hire more people we
just hired a new associate producer in
the middle of coronavirus because our
business is doing well and if you if you
allow the government to get out of the
way and elect allow you to keep what you
earn
I'm pretty sure that everyone watching
this knows what to do with their money
better than the government does so if so
I would say the one thing is when you
get to that moment because it will
happen you know we can talk about all
this stuff at the idea level low taxes
states rights all of these things but if
you live your life sort of congruently
with that if you live your life where
you're trying to apply your ideals into
your life at some point it will click
and then suddenly there will be a real
moment right in front of you where
you'll be like holy cow the stuff that
I've been talking about here's the pair
of the papers here are the numbers and
and it's in front of me and now I know
that I'm not just saying it I'm living
it
I got to ask you one last question
because I have to know this the first
time I was on your show was right after
I think Donald Trump was elected and you
asked me about Donald Trump and I told
you that I had had this fear that there
was a 5% chance that he might be Adolf
Hitler but other in that other 95%
chance he was much better than Hillary
Clinton to me he's turned out to be a
really good president he's done a very
good job he reminds me of the kind of
boss you have who you sometimes don't
like but he knows how to run the
business you know and I think that
that's a kind of interesting thing
politically you know you've changed
thought philosophically I've watched you
change philosophically have you changed
politically is there a point where you
start to say you know what I'm gonna put
my vote where my philosophy is even if
it means voting for someone like Trump
that I don't like that much yeah oh man
this is the the big finish on this one
claim in good question so first off let
me let me give you credit on something
else because I was also with you I was
with The Daily wire guys the night of
the election and you said something that
has I've quoted it a million times
because I think it was so on point we
everyone was shocked about what was
happening and you said you know what a
beautiful thing in America that it shows
you the flexibility of our system that
the thing that everyone said couldn't
happen that every pollster every expert
everyone on TV every bun did that the
thing that they just said couldn't
happen just happened what an incredible
society we live in that that sort of
things are fun yeah how much more fun
and and and all of that stuff and that's
not even you weren't even commenting on
Trump specifically you were just saying
like the reality of what just happened
is so beautiful to answer your question
I will tell you this so I am a
registered Democrat in this state
because there is so much Democrat power
in this state and I wanted to be able to
vote in the primaries so I voted for Joe
Biden excuse me in the primaries but it
was really just a vote against Bernie I
that was what I viewed as this truly
dangerous set of ideas Biden it was sort
of like just just take the vote you know
something like that but I will tell you
this I also vote you know I voted
against every single measure in there
that increased taxes every single thing
and you have to read them and they're
completely confusing and they say things
like you know are you five hundred
million more dollars for education and
if you just look at the headline you're
like well of course I want
more education 5 and then new you have
to read read read read read and on the
bottom it says and this will be an
intact for nine years and then only can
be repealed by vote but no one ever
votes to take education away you just
always vote to put more money into it
so I would say I would say in effect I
have no party I don't think having a
party is actually that important there's
a functional utility to having a party
in states where you can only vote in a
primary by one party but I don't
consider myself a Democrat I don't I
don't consider myself a republican do I
have far more in common with Republicans
obviously and to directly answer your
question I would say at this point I've
done a lot I think to save the word
liberal I think I've really tried and
I've been one of the people that have
really tried to save it so that so that
a guy like you or a guy like ben shapiro
could say yeah and the true sense i'm a
classical liberal and that really is
modern conservatism so i would say more
than anything else in a way I'm a modern
conservative if if conservatism is what
I'd now believe it to be that it isn't
that you have to buy all of these ideas
but you can have some outlier ideas but
basically believe in the bedrock
principles of America then I would say
I'm a modern conservative and I would
just say one other thing which is that
defending my liberal principles has
become a conservative position that's
amazing I that's I always say that too I
always say I'm a conservative because
I'm a liberal it's true
don't burn this book it's terrific and
I'm glad to see that more people are
buying it and are burning it though I
know a lot of it we just want to cross
out the first word of the title but it's
always great to talk to you Dave thanks
a lot Craven thanks for doing this and I
know you're back on the show I think in
June we're doing it in person regardless
of what Eric art said he says what do
you say about that I will be there with
with my big black mask on you'll see me
that's it thank you my friend thanks a
lot it's great talking to Dave if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell